Snow White
[Music]
a version of the tale by the
fablecottage.com
once upon a time in a kingdom very far
away there lived a king and a queen
the King was handsome and kind everybody
loved him but the real ruler of the
kingdom was his wife the queen
before she became Queen she worked in
the castle kitchen
she was very poor
but she was also very beautiful and
funny and very good at Scrabble
so the king fell in love with her and
married her
the king loved the queen very much
but the queen was always afraid that the
king would meet someone more beautiful
luckily the queen had a magic mirror
the mirror saw everything and knew
everything
every day the queen looked at herself in
the mirror and asked magic mirror on the
wall who is the most beautiful of all
and the mirror replied you are my queen
you are the most beautiful woman in the
whole world
the queen was happy she knew there was
nobody in the world as beautiful as her
but one day everything changed
the queen stood in front of the mirror
and asked her usual question
magic mirror on the wall who is the most
beautiful of all
and the mirror replied you are very
beautiful my queen but the most
beautiful woman in the world is
Snow White
the queen was shocked who is this snow
white she asked the mirror
Snow White works in the castle kitchen
she has hair black as night leps as red
as roses and skin his way to snow as of
etm this morning she is a wee wee pity
bit more beautiful than you
yelled the queen
she stomped her feet she pulled her hair
then she sat down and sobbed
I will lose everything
the queen was afraid and that fear
turned her heart cold and hard
she called a trusted Hunter to her room
find the girl
she ordered
far far away
take her deep into the woods and then
the queen looked deep into the Hunter's
eyes she must never come back
the hunter found Snow White and took her
into the forest
when they reached the deepest darkest
part of the forest the hunter stopped
whispered run fast and far and don't
ever go home
Snow White watched the hunter disappear
well I can't go home now she muttered
she looked around at the dark and Silent
Forest it started to rain
but I can't stay here either
okay feet let's go
Snow White ran and ran she ran across a
stream up a hill and down into a dark
Valley
she ran all morning
by midday her pale skin and Rosy Cheeks
were covered in mud and scratches
by early afternoon her long black hair
was full of sticks and leaves
by night she was not beautiful anymore
she was tired hungry and shivering with
cold
but then Snow White smelled wood smoke
in the air
she followed the smell and found a
cottage in the woods
there was a warm Golden Glow from the
windows
she knocked on the door
hello she called out
is anyone home
there was no answer
she pushed the door open and went inside
the cottage were seven tiny beds seven
tiny chairs and a roaring fire
a big table was covered with dirty
dishes
Snow White was very hungry and thirsty
she found some bread and ate the whole
loaf
she found some milk and drank the whole
bottle
then she sat in front of the fire to get
warm
and just like that she fell asleep
when she woke up there were seven dwarfs
standing around her
Snow White rubbed her eyes
who are you she said
this is our house said one dwarf angrily
who are you
shh you're scared her said another
aunt she
said yet another
can I stay with you asked Snow White it
seems I can't go home
the dwarves whispered amongst themselves
they agreed
but only if you help us wash the dishes
we hate washing dishes
the deal said Snow White
and so Snow White found a new home with
the Seven Dwarfs every morning she
washed the dishes and every morning as
the dwarves left for work they said be
careful don't open the door for anyone
and thank you for watching the dishes we
really hate washing dishes
back at the castle the queen was feeling
better
she thought Snow White was gone forever
but she was still a little afraid
come and play a Scrabble with me my love
shouted the king from the bottom of the
stairs
you can go first
maybe later Dearest
hide the queen
he stood in front of her magic mirror
magic mirror on the wall who is the most
beautiful of all
the mirror replied you are very
beautiful my queen
but the girl Snow White is the most
beautiful woman in the world
Snow White is alive shouted the queen
she is living with the Seven Dwarfs in
the forest said the mirror last night
she was not very beautiful but as of 1pm
today she is more beautiful than you
rats shouted the queen
she went to her closet and got her old
coat and old boots
I'll have to kill her myself
she ran out of the palace jumped into
her fastest carriage and sped off
towards the forest
Snow White was reading beside the fire
when there was a knock on the door
knock knock
she peeked through the window
there was a woman holding a basket of
fruit
the woman had a beautiful face but she
was wearing an old dress and old boots
fruit fresh fruit apples and bananas and
pears and oranges
oh I want some fruit thought Snow White
the woman saw Snow White through the
window
oh dear said the woman
do you want some fruit I have delicious
apples today
I love apples said Snow White but I'm
not supposed to open the door for anyone
those apples might be poisoned
oh how silly said the woman
she cut an apple in half
here you can taste half and I will eat
the other half
that way you know it's not poisoned
Snow White opened the door
the woman gave one half of the Apple to
Snow White and ate the other half
when Snow White saw the woman eating the
juicy Apple her mouth watered
she couldn't stop herself
she took a big bite of the Apple
almost immediately Snow White fell to
the ground
the Apple was poisoned but only on one
half
the Queen's side with relief quickly she
got back into her carriage and rode back
to the castle
when the dwarves arrived home they found
Snow White lying on the floor
they yelled in her ears they tickled her
feet they poured cold water on her face
but she didn't wake up
is she dead
past one dwarf
she doesn't seem to be alive
said a second
and so the dwarfs made a glass coffin
for their beloved friend
they set it on a table in a beautiful
part of the forest surrounded by flowers
Snow White lay there for over a year
through spring summer autumn and winter
one day a prince from a different
kingdom was walking through the forest
with his dog
he saw Snow White's strange glass coffin
he brushed off the leaves and saw Snow
White inside
just then he tripped over his dog and
knocked the coffin off the table
Snow White rolled out of the coffin and
onto the grass
oh no oh dear oh
Fiddlesticks the prince shouted
but then an amazing thing happened
the piece of poisoned Apple that was
stuck in Snow White's throat fell out
and she began to cough
the prince rushed to help her
he coughed
I beg your pardon said the prince
no
more
that night the queen stood in front of
the magic mirror and asked her question
magic mirror on the wall who is the most
beautiful of all
and to her surprise the mirror said
you are very beautiful my queen
but Snow White is again the most
beautiful woman in the world
what Scream the queen and in her anger
she picked up a shoe and threw it at the
mirror
the mirror smashed into a thousand
pieces and the magic inside it was
released
screamed the queen
she collapsed on the floor and fell into
a deep sleep
while she slept the queen had a strange
dream
in Her Dream she was dancing in Hot Iron
shoes
her feet burned and burned but she
couldn't stop dancing
when the queen woke up from this
terrible dream it was morning
the Sun was shining and the queen felt
different
the magic mirror's spell was broken so
she didn't feel anxious or jealous
anymore
she felt
free
she went downstairs to find her husband
she really wanted to play Scrabble
and what happened to Snow White
the dwarfs were very happy to see Snow
White alive
they invited the prince for dinner
when the prince learned that nobody
liked washing dishes
he bought them a dishwasher
everybody lived happily ever after
[Music]